Welcome to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Three, the Danish economy, Episode One: the welfare society and how it grew.
Let's open with a number.
According to the IMF, the International Monetary Fund, Denmark is the world's ninth richest country out of a total of 192 countries, and the third richest of the 27 EU countries.
Gross domestic product, GDP, per inhabitant, that is, the value of the total Danish production over one year divided among each of the country's six million inhabitants, was in 2026 83,000 American dollars, corresponding to just under 540,000 kroner.
But every society has only limited resources, meaning money.
That also applies to rich countries like Denmark.
The word "economy" itself comes from Greek and means "household".
That is, how you manage income and expenses.
That is why economics is also politics.
Because one of the questions that matter most to both the population and the politicians is how the resources should be distributed, and how we make the economy grow.
The Danish economy is often described as a mixed economy.
That means it works within the framework of a private market economy, but that the public sector also plays a big role in the economy.
Some goods and services are produced, bought and sold on the private market, for example food, furniture or taxi rides.
Others, typically services, for example education, hospital treatment or childcare, are offered by the public sector and paid for by taxes and duties.
In addition, the public sector moves a lot of money between citizens, through transfer incomes such as unemployment benefit, cash benefit and pensions.
The private and the public sector depend on each other.
Private business earns money and secures jobs, so that tax is paid, which among other things finances public welfare.
Conversely, the public education system, for example, secures qualified labour for business, while the public health service ensures that companies' employees recover faster and can return after illness, and day-care institutions ensure that children can be looked after so their parents can go to work.
The Finance Act for 2026 is the total budget for the state's expenditure and income.
This chapter describes some overall characteristics of the Danish economy in three areas: the welfare society, business life, and the labour market.
We begin with the welfare society.
The Danish welfare society is built on a principle that the individual citizen has both rights and duties.
Citizens who meet certain conditions have the right to the welfare society's benefits.
But the individual citizen also has a duty to contribute to the community.
Partly by paying tax, partly by working, if you can.
If you are outside the labour market and receive help, you also have a duty to make an active effort yourself to get back to the labour market.
All in all, this way of thinking is an expression of a kind of informal contract between the state and the citizens, with both duties and rights.
The Danish model of the welfare society has many features in common with the other Nordic countries.
People often talk about the Nordic model.
There are also many similarities with other rich countries, but there are some things where the Danish, and Nordic, welfare model stands out.
First: the state has a big responsibility for the citizens' welfare from the cradle to the grave.
There is childcare for all children.
Children and young people have access to free education.
Everyone is guaranteed treatment in case of illness.
There is help or care for the elderly and others who cannot manage on their own.
And there is financial support for those who cannot work and support themselves.
Second: most welfare benefits are financed by the whole population together via taxes and duties.
In many other countries, welfare benefits are mostly financed through social contributions paid by employees and employers.
In Denmark, the right to benefits is normally not dependent on having been in work and having paid social contributions, as is the case in several countries south of Denmark in Europe.
Third: welfare is made available to all citizens when they meet the conditions for receiving it.
Great emphasis is placed on service tasks that relieve the family.
This applies especially to childcare, nurseries, kindergartens and after-school care, and elderly care, home help, nursing homes and so on.
Several European countries have in certain areas been inspired by the Nordic welfare model.
The Danish way of arranging the welfare society makes it possible for both men and women to take an active part in the labour market, even if they have children.
In Danish families with children, both the father and the mother typically work full time or almost full time.
Here too, the European countries have moved in the same direction as the Nordic ones.
Now, how did we get here?
The development of the Danish welfare model.
In all societies, it is the adults who can work who take care of the elderly, of the children, and of those who for one reason or another cannot manage on their own.
Historically, this has often been organised within the individual family or in local communities.
In Denmark, a steadily larger part of these tasks has gradually been taken over by the welfare state.
This has happened by gradually creating a system in which all of society's citizens have a right to get financial and practical help on the basis of uniform criteria.
The first steps towards the welfare society we know today were taken in the 1890s.
It happened in a time of great economic and social change.
Agriculture was reorganised, industry emerged, and the towns grew.
With the changes to the old agricultural and craft society, a number of private social arrangements disappeared.
Instead, the state increasingly began to take care of the citizens who needed help.
More, and gradually more fixed, rules came about for who could be granted social benefits in case of illness, accident, unemployment and old age.
More and more people also got access to the benefits.
In 1933, as part of the so-called Kanslergade Agreement, a major social reform was carried out.
With the reform, 55 social laws were gathered into four people's insurance laws, folkeforsikringslove.
A higher degree of the rights principle was also carried out, that is, clearer rules about when and how much help the individual citizen could get.
Until then, it was largely up to the individual municipality to assess whether a citizen had the right to help, and how much could be given.
The reform also abolished most of the so-called declassification provisions in the social legislation.
That is, it made it the main principle that you could not lose your right to vote or other civil rights because you received help from the public sector.
The Kanslergade Agreement was made in 1933, during the economic crisis of the 1930s, so the problem it was meant to solve was economic.
The most important tracks towards the present welfare society were laid in the 1950s and 1960s.
Several of the fundamental principles of the welfare society were established here.
The social safety net was expanded, among other things with the old-age pension laws in 1956 and 1964, which introduced the old-age pension for all elderly people and not only for the weakest elderly.
So the first old-age pension law came in 1956, and a second followed in 1964.
And the service benefits emerged.
Previously the state had especially given cash benefits, that is, financial help to citizens who had lost their income due to unemployment, illness and accident, or old age.
But in this period, the welfare society also began to include a number of service benefits, which took over tasks that the family had previously been alone in taking care of.
That applied not least to childcare and home help for the elderly.
The principle of help to the citizen in need was supplemented to a higher and higher degree by a principle that the entire population, rich as well as poor, can benefit from the different benefits.
It was especially from the middle of the 1960s to the end of the 1970s that the big expansion of the service benefits took place.
It happened at the same time as almost all women, also those who were married, came out onto the labour market, so that the stay-at-home housewife almost disappeared.
From 1980 to around the year 2000, this development continued, with the majority of married women going from part-time to full time or almost full time.
It was especially the public sector's takeover of childcare and elderly care and so on that made this possible.
Nearly all children between 1 and 6 years get childcare, while most 7 to 10-year-olds are looked after in an after-school scheme after school.
Maternity and parental leave has also been extended several times, from a very few weeks in the 1970s to the 52 weeks with full unemployment benefit rates that have applied since 2002.
Here is your recap for Episode One.
Denmark is the world's ninth richest country out of 192, and the third richest of 27 EU countries.
GDP per inhabitant in 2026 was 83,000 dollars, just under 540,000 kroner.
Denmark has a mixed economy.
The welfare model rests on rights and duties, and has three special features: the state is responsible from cradle to grave; most benefits are financed by taxes rather than social contributions; and welfare is available to all who meet the conditions.
The first steps came in the 1890s.
In 1933, the Kanslergade social reform gathered 55 laws into four people's insurance laws.
The first old-age pension law came in 1956, and a second in 1964.
The Kanslergade Agreement of 1933 was about the economic crisis.
The big expansion of services was from the mid-1960s to the late 1970s.
Parental leave has been 52 weeks with full benefits since 2002.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
When was the first law on the old-age pension adopted?
Option A: 1933.
Option B: 1956.
Option C: 1982.
[DA] Hvornår blev den første lov om folkepension vedtaget?  A: 1933  |  B: 1956  |  C: 1982
The answer is B: 1956.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: 1956
Question 2.
What problems was the Kanslergade Agreement of 1933 meant to solve?
Option A: Economic problems.
Option B: Environmental problems.
Option C: Integration problems.
[DA] Hvilke problemer i samfundet skulle Kanslergadeforliget fra 1933 især løse?  A: Økonomiske problemer  |  B: Miljømæssige problemer  |  C: Integrationsproblemer
The answer is A: Economic problems.
It appeared in the June 2021, November 2022 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Økonomiske problemer
That's the end of this part.
Well done.